[Music]
[Music]
Blakely has the most difficult job as
Cincinnati Zoo he has to play with
babies all the time he's never shown any
aggression or snapped if he gets upset
kind of like any mom would he just
leaves the room my name is dawn Strasser
and we're at the Cincinnati Zoo and
Botanical Gardens Blakely is a five year
old Australian Shepherd we got him from
a rescue and I use him in a nursery as a
nanny or a companion dog this is about
you and you're taking a nap blakeley's
here for the main purpose of teaching
the babies the correct animal cues as
they grow up so when they are introduced
back to their own kind they know what
appropriate behavior is he teaches them
how to play how to interact I can tell
them no don't bite me but I'm not an
animal and I don't give the same cues
that he can so we make a great team
[Music]
Blakely has worked with cheetahs ocelots
a-talkin fettered foxes a warthog
Wallabies
to name a few he's working with four
baby cheetahs right now it's been a long
seven weeks for him with these little
cheetah cubs and he's I think tired
because he's on alert for 24 hours a day
if they start making too much noise
he'll come and get us like something's
not right something's not right he's
kind of like a second set of eyes for us
too a lot of times they still recognize
each other like Dale to talk and he
raised when they see each other he'll
they'll still run up front and grunt at
him and he'll kind of jump up on the
wall and kind of like hey how you doing
thank you yeah well I like to think I
have an office but I'm pretty sure it's
his
[Music]
this is a male tree Pangolin he is six
months old critically endangered and
under-researched the tree penguin is a
mammalian species like no other down
throughout Asia and Africa pangolins can
be traced back 66 million years meaning
they lived amongst dinosaurs they're the
only mammals on earth covered in scales
which account for about 20% of their
body weight these large protective
scales are made of keratin the same
thing human nails and hair are made from
tree penguins use their long claws to
climb on trees and branches in an
endless search for prey baby penguins
like the one here get around by riding
their mothers tails though they have
poor eyesight and hearing there's strong
sense of smell and elastic tongue allows
them to catch a meal of mercy ants and
termites when the penguin senses danger
it will curl up into a bowl making it
almost invincible in the wild humans
however are a dangerous threat the
Pangolin scales are thought to have
healing properties though there's no
science to back that up because of that
penguins are the most heavily trafficked
mammals in the world worth almost $300
per pound on the black market no one
knows how many penguins are left but we
do know that their number is shrinking
fast this is the tree penguin
[Music]
the difference between along with ants
and other animals they need this process
of learning they learn by imitating they
learn by observing so that's why we
create this forest schools where they
can learn from each other this is the
master animal rescue center for
orangutans in Japan we have now 102 or
annuitants we come across around Athens
that are kept as pets illegally we also
rescued them from the abbot and that is
disappearing when we rescue wrong turns
especially when they are a small babies
these babies have lost their mothers
normally and along with them will remain
with its mother for as long as 7 to 8
years of their lives and this is the
process when the orangutans have the
chance to learn from their mothers how
to survive in the world what to eat what
not to eat what are the ten years of the
forest what we have to do is to teach
them how to survive in the world in this
forest schools one of the first ones is
how to be off the ground
how to spend time on the top of the
trees which it might seem like a very
simple thing but actually some of these
orangutans I have been living with
people and having chained up or living
in small cages at the beginning they are
afraid to climb a tree the ultimate goal
of this rehabilitation is release this
animal sack to the wild what is special
with the wrong witnesses they are very
similar to humans if we don't care about
wrong returns I think it's even more
difficult that we are going to care
about any of the other species if they
get a stinked in
they will be extinct from the face of
the world so we have to do something
about this now this is aya and sugar two
adorable clouded leopard cubs don't be
fooled by the youthful spirit clouded
leopards are some of the most shy
mysterious and elusive cats besides
their shy nature they have a steadily
declining population making it even
harder to spot them in the wild
as far as big cats go clouded leopards
are the smallest these two little girls
will top out at around 3 feet when fully
grown natives throughout Asia they live
in diverse habitats from the rain
forests of Indonesia to the foothills of
the Himalayas
they pack a powerful bite - as they have
the largest canine teeth relative to
body size of any wild cat they have
short powerful legs and ankles that
convert eight backwards making them
elite climbers beyond a quickly
shrinking habitat perching remains a
huge problem as their skin claws teeth
burns and meat are all sold on the black
market this is the clouded leopard
[Music]
milk
it's the elixir all mammals feed to
their young deep inside the National Zoo
in Washington DC a team of scientists
are devoted to unlocking the wonders of
the white gold to help animals like baby
fiona but more on that later welcome to
the world's largest collection of exotic
animal milk okay let's get to it
meet dr. Michael power can I call you
Mike sure okay Mike what do you do here
I'm the curator of the exotic animal
milk repository at the Smithsonian's
National Zoo
it's the largest bias species count a
number of samples of milk in the entire
world we have samples that have been
collected from all over the world that
we keep in frozen storage animals like
armadillos bats giraffe giant anteater
Asian elephant African lion
cheetahs Tigers sea lions and zebra I
hate to ask but how do you get the milk
well I'll let the Tang show you the tang
is a critically endangered Bornean
orangutan so this is the classic
collaboration between a scientist and
the animal care staff their incredible
work and effort it be able to training
the animals to be able to accept this
procedure to where they voluntarily
donate samples so now that we know the
how we have to ask why the exotic mammal
milk repository serves two critical
purposes one is basic science it's
simply trying to understand in a sense
the origin of milk and the other is a
very practical pragmatic purpose in the
fact that we have to occasionally
handler animals and therefore we have to
come up with a milk replacer formula
okay so when a baby can't be fed by
their mother you guys help come up with
a formula that's as close to the
mother's milk as possible have you heard
about baby Fiona the cincin
zoo is the baby hippo who stole in the
hearts of people all over the country
baby fiona was born six weeks premature
she's a Nile hippo and no other baby
hippo had been hand raised in North
America and so we needed to put together
a milk formula to be able to feed her to
have her grow so we worked together with
the exotic animal milk repository at the
National Zoo
to come up with a formula to feed baby
Fiona so how's Fiona doing now
milk is almost removed from her diet we
are very happy that baby Shona is happy
and healthy and growing very well
awesome back to Mike so what's next the
milk repository has samples from over a
hundred and eighty species of mammals
and that sounds pretty impressive until
you realize that there's anywhere from
five to six thousand species of mammals
so we have only sampled maybe three
percent of the mammals still only a tiny
tip of the iceberg compared to what we
could be learning
[Music]